where you see right behind us is our
first commercial building about 1.7
million square feet coach L'Oreal s ap
what we have next to this building is
about a million square foot seven storey
retail building we've been working on
different tenants right now and leasing
you probably heard that we've been
negotiating with Neiman Marcus to anchor
that with it too
today's big anchor tenants you take them
yourself through the site
when deals are being done at this size
the CEO of those organizations their
investors their shareholders all all
want to come through and touch and feel
what's gonna happen this store will be
one of their largest urban store
when they come here it like you want to
show the how big this place yeah you
have to have some vision right so it's
not you can't come here and just look at
the construction you have to see our
plans and hear the whole story because
what's going to happen here it's really
creating the new center of New York City
you want everybody who's hanging out
over by Central Park or people who are
hanging out down the High Line has
become one of the biggest tourist
attractions in New York City there's a
park here dividing 10th and 11th Avenue
that will go six blocks north called
Hudson Boulevard and that glass dome
like the entry to the new number seven
subway line that number seven subway
line it's three stops at six minutes the
Grand Central Station and so again
bringing kind of all the transportation
infrastructure necessary for this to
work and that's why our commercial
tenants and
essentially what you want is you want
someone to be able to live here work
here shop here eat here and have their
entertainment here they could basically
live here six walk with 18 million
square feet this is bigger than most
downtown's in the United States so
absolutely this is a live-work-play
environment with all the parks 50% of
our land area 28 acres his public open
space that is an incredibly open
environment unlike anywhere else in New
York City there'll be more green space
per square foot than almost anywhere
else in the city
right where we're standing and then all
the way to the north this will be our
next commercial office building roughly
2.6 2.7 million square feet this will be
the third tallest building in New York
with the highest outdoor observations
but def i don't get it i mean we already
have that kind of space tell me yeah so
in New York City 65% of the buildings in
New York City or over 50 years old and
if you think about how technology has
changed and the way business has changed
the way people do business has changed
over that period of time our
infrastructure and buildings haven't
kept pace the building's that we're
putting up today are unlike any others
that exist in New York New York City is
growing right there are new
neighborhoods I think people are moving
from a residential perspective from
uptown to downtown that trend is long
kind of started it's been going on for
quite a few years now if you look at
residential rents this is an interesting
statistic for people that know New York
we get our highest rents in New York
City in West Chelsea and in our new
building right here we get our lowest
grants per square foot in New York City
on the Upper East Side so if you would
have told in New Yorker ten years ago
that you're going to get the highest
rents in New York here in West Chelsea
they would say you're crazy don't you
live on the Upper East Side I'm moving